sporadic gunfire has been heard in
Sudan's capital Khartoum despite a new
seven-day humanitarian ceasefire Sudan's
Army and the paramounty rapid support
forces have been locked in a power
struggle since mid-april at least 850
people have been killed and more than a
million have been forced from their
homes in the conflict
Eva Morgan has more from omdraman
within the first few minutes of the
ceasefire between the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army coming into
effect loud explosions were heard in the
Northern parts of the capital Khartoum
as well as in the southern part of the
capital we spoke to Residents in East
Nile which is in the northeast of the
capital and they say that they were able
to hear sporadic gunfire and heavy
artillery and that they can hear the
sound of the fighter jets flying
overhead now that's all a violation of
the agreement that was signed between
the rsf and the Sudanese Army as per the
agreement fighter jets should not be
flying overhead there should be no heavy
artillery being fired especially in
residential areas and the rsf should
Brigade from hospitals or at least allow
hospitals to operate as well as other
facilities such as water and power
plants to be fixed for people who have
been cut off from Power and Water
Supplies to regain access to them many
people here in the capital said that
they were hoping that this ceasefire
would hold but they were very cautiously
optimistic they said that they were
waiting to see what happens on Tuesday
and Wednesday because they have seen how
previous these fires between the rsf and
the Sudanese Army have played out they
wanted the ceasefire to hold because
they want humanitarian Aid to come in
especially after supplies in the market
has deflated since the start of the
conflict but for now people say that
after hearing the fighter jets overhead
and after hearing heavy artillery in
parts of Khartoum they're not sure if
this ceasefire will actually hold or if
it will end up like the rest of the
ceasefires that have been previously
agreed upon by both the rapid support
forces and the Sudanese Army Hippa
Morgan Al Jazeera on durman